Here's the answer.
We'll start with the polynomial a and
for this I get the values 2, 5, 2, 5.
You could have done
the calculation however you liked.
To emphasize that we can view this
process as matrix multiplication,
I've written out
the Vandermonde Matrix here.
For b, we just change the coefficients.
And we get 3, 5, -1, -3 for
the values of the polynomial.
Multiplying in the value
domain is simple.
We just multiply the corresponding
values at these inputs,
and that gives me 6, 25, -2, and -15.
This gives me a matrix equation
here in terms of the desire
to coefficients of
the product polynomial C, and
solving this gives me the answer
1 + 2x + x squared + 2x cubed.
Which, you can easily verify is correct
by convolving those two sets of
coefficients in the normal way.